[Music]
[Applause]
because to some degree and i mentioned
that
there's no pressure and there's no
expectations that being said i like him
on defense i like his length and you see
him getting the
starting assignment that double teaming
booker who split the double team
uh like swiss season went right through
it
devin booker
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of these files glenn are ticky
tack files that can be avoided
yeah you're 100 right chris and one of
the things that phoenix likes to do yeah
it's um i guess it depends on how old
you are right
i was hoping you wouldn't say that now
thomas bryant just gets called for a
fast price for the corner here's bonga
bonga shoot there and that shot instead
tried to pass another turnover
booker his baseline jumper and a timeout
now
here by scott brook that right there is
an area where rui hachimora has to
improve he has the easy look he needs to
finish it like deandre ayton does on the
other end what a tremendous environment
the nba has provided for them two for
one opportunity right now for phoenix
booker his step back for three
boy napier just seems like he just
doesn't have that
that pop in his game that first step
that he normally has to finish
booker got it in the foul i thought
devin booker got away with a travel when
he first caught that ball
going at it with the left hand what does
he look like there
that's also a very big delta because the
wizards
have gone only seven times the wizards
you know no one's missed a free throw
this game there's seven of seven
it's a good offensive set you know they
they worked the ball they
reversed it got it off the strong side
and that's how you're going to get open
looks
here's eight and now for three able to
hit that
when bryant couldn't and if that's the
case you want to take it off the glass
and get some easy ones before the
defense is set up the lob
from booker in four games of the eighth
place
team in the east at the end of these
games as deandre
ayton just goes up and over mo
wagner for that alley-oo boy there's the
little alley you pass
and moe got there way too late see the
point guard position has been cold in
this game but
if he can get going here in the fourth
maybe he regains his name as the closer
but you can't do that
here's booker against troy brown jr his
step back
he is just lethal what they were in the
three scrimmages
all three were single digits now trying
to see if they can close this gap
the lob to ayton's too high still able
to recover though
scott brooks going with troy brown jr on
booker down the stretch and he is just
this
this is an elite elite scorer
rocking that defender to sleep rock
about baby
looking for ayton difficult pass to
handle deandre
now against bryants fading away
there's a reason why he was the number
one overall pick
bridges to the corner ayton with the
shot clock at one hits his second
three he's got 24.